in your book yes gutsy women right these
are women who have to be recognized this
is your version of the Academy Awards
yeah you were saying to history let's
not forget these women right and and to
people today who I hope will read it
find out about them fired yeah
Helen Keller you're right listen no one
can know because I mean hosing blind yep
death yep
and I also highlight and Sullivan her
teacher because what a great great
instructor she was to get a Helen
colored unlocked for the world yes you
recognized Bella Abzug or Jorge Bella
fabulous congresswoman you know who I
would have put in there Joan Rivers what
do you think of that that's an
interesting idea didn't ask me a my book
I included Ellen DeGeneres and you
included Ellen and she is a hero to me
she's a hero to me - you know I remember
when she came out she had the sitcom she
came out I was very proud of her because
again in show business I don't care what
you say we remember the days of Rock
Hudson when they say he comes out yes
the end of his leading man career and
even today when somebody comes out it's
a big to-do right and she and and is
that the reason you admire her yes and
and the way she handled it yeah I mean
she is the one who finally said I can't
continue pretending I'm somebody I'm not
what did you think when she got
criticized she's sitting next to George
Bush and she was joking around with him
nothing wrong with that that was insane
right more of that right
come on civility decorum listening and
talking to each other
enough with the chants and the insults
let's have a conversation
do you know what she was showing George
Bush at the time on her phone I do not a
painting of mine that I did a watercolor
you are kidding me
Allen told me that well because I got in
trouble you should talk to bourgeois
paint it I am a water colorist than he
is a water colorist and she thought it
would be and she's an admirer of some of
my watercolors that is terrific in that
crazy did you take lessons like he did I
did take lessons I just don't do for you
I love it